hi in this video we are going to cover
computer security now in computer
security there's a couple things that
you guys might already know but you
might not know how to keep your computer
and your files safe now the first kind
of thing we're going to talk about is
something called a dictionary attack and
this has to do with your passwords when
you're creating a password some sites
make you do you know it's okay special
character here and more than one member
but not sequentially and you're like you
have to have an extra letter that
doesn't the enemy they're working they
can be really really specific on how
complicated they have to be and it's
actually a little bit unnecessary the
kind of attacks they're trying to guard
you from are these dictionary attacks
which literally there are computers that
are programmed to go down all of the
words in the dictionary and try them as
passwords for every username in a system
for example so if your password is
kangaroo they're probably going to break
in your account now most people's
passwords are not this simple but that
doesn't matter they're trying to mass
attack everybody's account with this
type of strategy and all I need is one
or two people or one or two percent of
the people to have these simpler
passwords that are just a word or
numbers that are in order now in general
when you're creating a password you want
to have some capitals some numbers some
symbols sure but one of the best ways
you can mix it up is just to throw some
random letters in there to really make
sure that it's not a word that they're
going to find in a dictionary it's not a
common name nothing that's too
sequential if you go now phishing is
have you forgotten one of those emails
that's found like Amazon or they say
you're for their friend's visa and they
need you to log in and fix something
right now or else you're going to lose
your account you're going to be fine you
know they come up with all these great
reasons why you need to log in right now
may provide you the link phishing is
something that generally targets the
older population that doesn't know
necessarily the difference between an
actual amazon.com and what looks to be
amazon.com there are two ways to
safeguard yourself from phishing one
look at the address in the browser if
it's
des amazon.com you're probably safe
it also should have an HTTPS that little
green thing next to ensure that it is
actually Amazon another way to do it is
to just exit that email open another
browser go to amazon.com and see if
there's any alerts they're most likely
there won't be unless it's obviously a
real threat encryption and HTTPS now if
you're at your banker you're on your
website for your bank maybe you're doing
different public place maybe you're at
Starbucks and you're in the Wi-Fi you
need to check your bank you might be
worried about your password security and
you should be anything that's said along
these packets might be intercepted by
someone else what you want to look for
is the HTTPS because that means that the
site you're setting the information to
is encrypting your information
encryption is just a scrambling up of
all the data and unless you have the
code to unlock the encryption it's just
Google just means nothing in general
whenever you're showing private or
sensitive information you want to check
for an HTTPS to make sure your
information is as safe as it can be have
a quick addendum about HTTPS while HTTPS
will protect you from people outside of
your network if there's anybody on your
network who like is connected to your
Wi-Fi or maybe wire with a wire
connected to your internet connection
HTTPS doesn't protect you from anybody
there so you still want to be careful
when you're on public Wi-Fi connection
couple other general tips don't share
passwords between important accounts say
your passwords very strong password but
if for example target comm gets hacked
into and that password there is a safe
password you have for your bank in your
email you might be kind of out of luck
um also don't download strange files a
lot of these kind of trojan or malware
or viruses that happen are in files you
need to download they disguise them as
well as they can but if your is not from
a trusted site you want to check for
that dot PDF or dot txt or dot jpg if
you don't recognize that or it's not if
you think you're downloading it
image and it's not an image playoff
format dope download it's that's too
fishy and once they're in there they can
pretty much run your computer from the
insects was pretty scary stuff another
way to keep yourself protected is keep
your software updated specifically
software that uses the Internet and
interfaces with the Internet one way
that the bad guys are trying to get into
your computer is finding holes and gaps
and security of older versions now those
bugs have been patched in new versions
so if you continuously update your
security and update your software you're
not going to have as many problems ah
these are really just like basic things
basic things you should know about how
to keep your information safe on your
computer